WELCOME TO COMMITTEE EVERYONE.
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL START
WITH A ROLL CALL IN ABSENCE OF
THE CHAIR RIGHT NOW? SO.
WHY DON'T YOU CALL THE ROLL?
FOR CALLING THE WRONG COLOR.
START WITH EACH YEAR. IRAQ HAD.
GREAT THERE BELOW HERE ACOSTA.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN. BONTA
COOLEY.
COOPER. DALY. GALLAGHER EDUARDO
GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY
LIVING.
IS HERE.
LOW RUBIO.
SOLACE.
WALDRON.
YEAH REQUIRED.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM OF THE AGENDA
MISTER COOLEY.
PROCEED.
OR TABLE AND ALCOHOL CANNABIS I
WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE'S
SUGGEST AMENDMENT THE ANALYSIS.
IT WOULD PROVIDE THAT ON PAGE TO
THE BILL LINE'S ELEVEN TO
FOURTEEN.
WE STRIKE THE CHANGES REINSTATE
THE EXISTING LANGUAGES ADOPTED
IN THE BUDGET BILL OUR PRIOR AND
I AGREED TO DOING THAT.
OTHER BILL DEALS GENERALLY WITH
ALCOHOL AND CANNABIS INFUSION.
THEREFORE THAT'S WHAT REMAINS IN
THE BILL. OF WE ARE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND AS
AMENDED YES AS AMENDED CORRECT.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU ANYWAY.
SUPPORT.
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BETSEY ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION AND MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEEING THAT ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS.
WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO QUICKLY.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING HIM
AND
AND MAKE US ADJUSTMENT.
THANK GOODNESS RENTAL CHAIR.
STAFF.
LOW SAID THAT YOU ARE MISTER
COOLEY FOR A WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF TO OUR GET
EVERYTHING IN ORDER. I SEE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS YOU HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL GRAY. AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
AYE ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE BONTA.
COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY. KILEY
AYE LACKEY.
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW.
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SOLACE
SO THIS AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THEY KEY MEMBERS
GOING TO DO ALL THINK IS A JERK
YEAH.
NDEM.
WHICH JUST. YEAH.
I LIKE THAT